An early example of beneficial government
regulation, to proof alcohol was simply to
test and verify that the contents of a barrel
of liquid was what it was claimed to be.
The process began in England around the 16th
century.
Its original purpose was not consumer protection,
but rather to ensure that the state (read:
the King) collected the proper amount of taxes
on the sale of the product (alcohol, called
proof spirits, was taxed at a higher rate).
The first method was imprecise at best, and
involved soaking a gun pellet in the liquid,
and then trying to light it on fire; if it
burned, it was classified as a proof spirit.
However, as alcohol’s flammability is dependent
on its temperature (the higher the temperature,
the more vapors the alcohol infused solution
will emit, and, therefore, the more flammable),
sometimes actual alcohol was passed off as
something less (and taxed at the lower rate).
Nonetheless, frequently the product would
catch fire, and by that the authorities would
know that the spirit (usually rum) was at
least 57.15% alcohol by volume (ABV), which
at that time was classified as being 100 proof.
As scientific skills improved, by the early
19th century, a far more accurate test was
developed which measured the liquid’s specific
gravity (the ratio of the density of a substance
to a reference, in this case distilled water).
Distilled water is actually denser than alcohol.
Accordingly, in 1816 a test was developed
that relied on the fact that at 11°C (51°F),
a 100 degree proof spirit (~57.15% ABV) would
weigh 12/13 that of distilled water.
As 57.15% is roughly equivalent to 4/7, in
the UK to convert a lower alcohol to proof,
you simply multiply the ABV by 7/4 (or 1.75);
so, if you had a delicious IPA with an ABV
of 6.9%, in the UK this would be 12.075 degrees
of proof, while a 100% ABV pure alcohol would
have a proof of 175 degrees.
In the US, this somewhat complicated method
was rejected (in an early example of tl;dr),
and instead proof is simply calculated by
doubling the ABV.
So, in the States, that IPA would be 13.8
proof, while Jack Daniels, with an ABV of
40%, is 80 proof.
Of course, some spirits far exceed these ABVs,
with a number of neutral grain and rectified
spirits reaching ABVs of 96% (168 degrees
of proof in the UK and 192 proof in the US).
In the United States, these alcohols are regulated,
if at all, by the particular states; for example,
Nevada prohibits the sale of alcohol in excess
of 80% ABV, and California prohibits the sale
of anything over 60% ABV.
Uncle Sam has singled out one alcohol in particular
for regulation, however, – absinthe.
Sometimes called the Green Fairy, this exotic,
strong spirit (ABV 45-75%) infused with green
anise, fennel, other herbs and most notably,
grand wormwood, fueled Paris’ Belle Époque
and is credited by some as inspiring a variety
of artistic movements (e.g. Surrealism, Impressionism,
Post-Impressionism, Modernism and Cubism),
as well as the writings of notables including
Oscar Wilde, Charles Baudelaire and Ernest
Hemingway.
In the early 1900s, a number of countries
banned absinthe (1912 in the US), due in equal
measure to a smear campaign conducted by the
wine industry, lurid tales of men under its
spell committing horrid violent crimes, and
the presumed presence of thujone, a chemical
compound that is said to be poisonous in large
amounts.
As it turns out, however, most absinthe has
very little thujone and easily meets all regulatory
requirements (in the US, no more than 10ppm).
Accordingly, beginning in about 2007, absinthe
returned to the US, both as imports from Europe
along with domestic producers springing up,
as well.